make these games your own we chose you
for a reason and it wasn't just because
I like the color orange Harry is
officially a daddy and back at work just
three days after welcoming his first
child with Megan Markel
deserting a little bit of facial hair as
well the 34 year old royal traveled to
the Netherlands to help launch next
year's Invictus games
thank you all for guarding Invictus
spirits and see you in 2020 and he was
beaming as he received gift after gift
for new son Archie Harrison
[Applause]
huh we don't think that's for you Harry
now despite flying solo to the event our
favorite ginger made sure to remind us
of its very important new role so I'm
just over the moon if you look closely
at the words on Harry's jacket you'll
notice the saying I am daddy highlighted
in yellow harry and megan introduced
their newborn son to the world on
wednesday and later revealed his full
name on instagram archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor
Megan gave birth to the couple's 7-pound
3-ounce bundle of joy on May 6th at 5:26
a.m. and the celebrations and good
wishes immediately began rolling in
they're very pleased and glad spoke my
brother to the patient's aunty parents
even fellow Brit James Corden offered
his advice for the new parents while
chatting with et on Wednesday well the
only advice I give to any new parent is
that until you have a child you just
don't you don't understand the capacity
of love that you can feel for somebody
else and the other thing is that that
you know time is going to start playing
tricks on them now like my son is 8 and
I feel like I feel like he took his
first steps yesterday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]